in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of absolute value
which you can view as how far are you
from zero
so for example
let's say that we have a bunch of people
living on a street and let's say that we
say that the school is at zero
and we could think about where other
people live
so let's say i live
three miles to the right of the school
maybe that's east
so this is where
i live
so that's me right over here
and that you live three miles to the
left of the school so this is where you
would be
three miles to the left or maybe we
could say that's to the west of the
school now you could say that your
position is at negative three miles
relative to the school and my position
is at positive three miles relative to
the school but what we might care about
is just how far are we from the school
and so there you could say well we're
each exactly three miles from the school
you're three miles from the school and i
am three miles from the school
and that's what absolute value is
actually trying to get at so for example
your position is negative three but if
we were to take the absolute value which
you denote by these two straight up down
bars around the number then we say
that's just going to be your distance
from 0 which is just going to be 3 miles
similarly
my position is at 3 miles positive 3
miles the absolute value of that is
going to be
drum roll please
it is going to be 3 as well you might
already see a pattern if you're taking
an absolute value of a negative number
you get the number without the negative
and if you take the absolute value of a
positive number it just equals itself
again but the reason why that is the
case is because we're just saying how
far is that thing from zero
let me give another example
let's say
that
we have some type of a cruise ship
and that's the water right over there
this is the cruise ship
let me draw it this big cruise ship nice
and big one has water slides on it and
whatever else whatever you would expect
from a huge cruise ship
and let's say we think about the height
of where the different floors are in the
ship and a natural place to think about
is based on where the sea level is so we
call that height
zero
now there's this big
waterfall pool type thing up here let's
just say it's a pool for simplicity on
the roof and let's say that that is
at an altitude of 80 feet
so we would call that at positive
80 feet
and let's say the engine room is right
over here and if you wanted to know its
position its height well it is going to
be below zero it's below sea level let's
say it's at negative
20 feet
so that would give you its position one
is 80 feet above the sea level and then
one is 20 feet below the sea level but
if you just wanted to know how far they
are well you could take the absolute
value how far is that roof deck pool
when you take the absolute value of 80
you're going to get
80. how far is that engine room from
zero how far is it from sea level
well the absolute value of negative 20
is going to be
20.